yeah and so I emailed Simon just kind of
on a whim while I was in Indonesia
jet-lagged and thought that it would be
cool if he was able to speak to our
class and within the first we melee
agreed which was really surprising
something why I thought maybe podcast
producers were more intimidating when
they are there's very nice people too
and so he is very graciously agreed to
kind of talk about how radio lab puts
together their podcasts and kind of
targets the general public but a lot of
the podcasts are wrong kind of current
science trends or kind of philosophical
questions that kind of are pretty deep
and they're trying to repack them for a
way that the general public finds
interesting or not you guys I mean just
in case some of you guys aren't aware
radio lab in 2007 got the National
Academies communication award for its
imaginative use of radio to make science
accessible to broad audiences and in
2010 and 2014 they got the Peabody
Awards for their podcast which I'm
pretty sure is basically like the Oscars
they do a very good job and I'll pass it
over to Simon and youth ourselves now is
it recording yes yes he does all right
cool um yeah it's good to be here good
to see all of your happy faces this this
afternoon so yeah it's like I guess I'm
more interested in having a discussion
than me lecturing about anything in
particular but a little bit about what
we are what we do and what I do
specifically for the show so yeah as
we've mentioned we're we're like a radio
documentary program so if you think like
I think like feature writing for a
magazine turned into the audio form or
like a film documentary turned into the
audio form and particularly what we try
to do is we try to find stories that are
filled with narrative tension so like
any movie or television show that you
watch they're creating a story that
makes you want to stick
makes you want to listen to what's or
watch what's gonna happen next but not
just that in our stories as well we're
trying to explore some question
typically typically through the
characters or through the individuals
story that we that were that we're
telling so I think the best example of
that was a couple years there one of one
example of this is I did a story several
years back profiling this Texas oil
tycoon who also happened to be a trophy
hunter and essentially he went to
Namibia
he paid $350,000 and bought the right to
shoot an endangered rhino in Namibia and
essentially this story then is from like
the moment he buys this thing through to
him shooting the thing exploring the
question like okay on its face this guy
seems like a total [ __ ] who is doing
terrible things for the world but is
that the case so it becomes a six
exploration of what is conservation in
the 21st century and how do things is
sort of an intuitive or ironic is
killing animals how does that feed back
into protecting them
now it's specifically what I do here is
I split my time about 50/50 between
being a reporter and being a producer so
that means half my time I'm reading
calling people conducting interviews and
then half the time essentially I'm
taking all of that tape that we get and
turning it into the thing that you hear
and that's a very long process or we'll
do sort of Draft after Draft after draft
of the story until we think it gets to a
point that we want the world to hear it
so yeah that's a little bit of what I do
what we do and I guess yeah let's I open
it up for questions or some sort of
discussion you guys can kind of direct
what you want what you want out of me
okay cool thank you does anybody first
burning question yes
[Music]
hi Carolina so I guess I was just
wondering with all caps you only have
like the ability to hear like voices
sounds like I guess how do you find that
against challenging or unique if you
don't have written words or any visuals
or anything like that
yeah well it's interesting it's why it
like writing for radio and storytelling
in radio is obviously different than in
other forms and so a lot of what we're
trying to do is take moves that are
being done in film or in in film
documentary typically actually film
we're looking to to good television
shows or movies and figure out like what
are the storytelling devices they're
using and how can we sort of recreate
those in an audio in a just a purely odd
audio medium so like an example of that
is like a one of my colleagues here that
was watching the opening scene - there
will be blood which is this just it
opens up to this panoramic shot of like
guessing it's western Texas and it then
goes into this story of this man like
picking at the ground trying to find oil
and so the question became like is there
a way to create a sort of sonic
representation of a place like like it
like a desert landscape and how do we do
that in a way that feels authentic to a
degree also subtle and I think what
ended up being done was like there was
some tape of somebody one of our
reporters who was out in the desert sort
of walking through and used hear them
breathing and you hear the wind blowing
through the microphone and then like
maybe a little little bit of music comes
in to not even further to the fact that
okay we're in the southwest this is
where the story is going to take place
the desert is a character in and of
itself in this piece so essentially it's
it's a strange act of translation from
from one medium to another but like just
as a practical note one thing we're
always trying to do in audios give you
the listeners something to look at which
sort of counterintuitive but uh like we
think of it that we're making movies for
your ears and in those movies like you
got to be able to see exactly what's
happening and we're where you need to be
able to imagine exactly what's happening
and we're using different sounds or
we're using different people's voices or
a variety of different techniques which
I could go into to accomplish that right
now how would you get those recordings
without recording like every step of
your day or do you do that like how do
you determine what time to bring out a
recorder yeah I'm just always like words
we're just always rolling and so yeah
it's a pain in the ass like I did a
piece a a couple months back following
this City Council New York City Council
candidate around for it was a profile of
this guy and I followed him around for
about eight months and at the end of it
I had like a hundred or 120 hours of
tape that was eventually cut down to an
80 minute story so yeah we're just like
we're always recording in the hopes that
you that you can capture some tiny
little moment that that in fact captures
the idea you're trying to explain I
don't care it seems like you're checking
me and unbiased as possible when you're
presenting these stories but oh do you
keep that unbiased especially if you're
doctoring into sometimes story format
yeah that's a really good question I the
like I don't know I don't know if
unbiased is the is the right way to talk
about it um what we're doing is we're
telling a story and a story inherently
has
a point of view and it inherently has
some sort of agenda like we're
manipulating you as the listener in very
specific moments to feel very specific
things or ask very specific questions
and like that's the actual craft of the
production processes like how can we
take this sort of mountain of tape and
sculpt it into something where you as
the listener have an experience and I
think what we try to do is with everyone
we talk to to meet them
simultaneously in a generous way where
we actually want to hear what they're
saying and we want to understand them
but at the same time in a very critical
way where it's my job as an interviewer
to stand in for you the listener and ask
the question that though it may be
uncomfortable in the moment is the
question that needs to be asked and so I
guess we're constantly we're constantly
forcing ourselves to stare logically at
the things that people are saying and
see if they make sense and if they don't
make sense we're gonna tell you it
doesn't make sense but if it does and we
can't argue our way out of it even if it
feels wrong to us in some way we're
gonna present that and I think that's
one thing I love about the Rhino hunter
story is like here's a guy they you
really hate with the get go you're we
and we sent you up to hate him and yet
at the end like I if we did our job
right like you're you certainly you
might like the guy and if you don't like
him at least you think he's reasonable
whereas you probably thought he was off
his rocker in the first 10 minutes of
the piece so I think if the I don't know
if it's about bias or I think it's about
just critically engaging with the ideas
and you as the listener essentially as a
listener to a show like radio lab or
This American Life or any number of
documentary programs like you you and
you as an you as a listener saying like
I trust you to manipulate me I trust you
to play with my emotions in a way that
will be fair
and to the people you're presenting and
that's how I look at it and I try to I
try to keep that in mind that make sense
or if you want you can try okay how like
what do you use before you go into
creating that podcast you have like a
storyboard or like like a scripture or
just kind of come to me you go in yes so
the process is so let's say I go and
report look Keith or a couple months
what I'm gonna be doing well I'm
reporting is taking all that tape so
typically an interview we do here is
about 90 minutes long I'm gonna take
that 90 minute interview and and cut it
down to like a 20 minute set of selects
as we call them and that sort of like
the hot hot tape from the from the
interview as well as sort of like a
presentation of like the arc of the
interview so let's say after two months
of reporting I've done ten interviews
I've got ten interviews that are now cut
down to 20 minutes long and at that
point I'm gonna go back and I'm gonna
listen to everything my editors are
gonna listen to everything and if I have
another producer who's gonna be working
with me they're gonna listen to
everything everything meaning the
selects that we have cut from there then
it becomes this sort of we'd call it a
storyboarding session and essentially
they like we just go around the room
telling each other what we think the
story is like I think we start so back
in 2015 buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh
buh but then Papa Papa ba and so to
understand this you got to back up
buh-buh-buh-buh-byeeeee and we just do
that sort of around the room over and
over again until we start to land on a
structure that sound that that seems
like it's going to work and by work I
mean like the that we can do it with the
tape that it's honest so for most more
than that that it that the emotional
moves that we're trying to make the ways
we're trying to make you feel we have
the tape to do it and like one thing
that sets us apart from other shows is
brief tangent is just how much we lean
on tape like this American life for
example I would
yes 70% of the of the words you hear in
an episode are are tracked narration
whereas I would say in our episodes it's
closer to 30% or 40% but anyway so once
we have what feels like a structure we
lay that out on paper just super basic
like the basic beats of the story like
we start here we meet this person here
then this happens this is because of
that the end and then essentially it
becomes this this game of running into
all of the problems that you didn't
predict when you built this storyboard
or this roadmap for yourself so
obviously like you're it's never gonna
translate perfectly you're never going
to have foreseen all of the potential
problems you're gonna run into when
you're writing in that storyboard and so
then we're just constantly revising or
trying new ways new structures either
macro or micro to present the ideas in
an order that is both compelling and in
a hopefully informative so it like and
I'll say like when an episode that we do
in most cases we go through like 20 or
30 iterations like we remake episode 20
or 30 times before I never goes out so
you're just guessing you're constantly
guessing until you get to a place that
you that you feel like you've landed in
the right spot so what's kind of an
average like you decide this is a topic
up for a podcast they're gonna work on
and then that final product is that is
that like a year in the making or is
that often yeah it totally totally
totally varies um I would say on yeah
it's so hard to even give an average
because like I said we just put out
essentially we threw together in three
days which we had never done before like
prior to this the quickest thing we've
ever turned around was a month but I
would say on average the stuff I work on
or I have worked on it's typically like
three months of reporting
and then you're looking at like a month
or two months of production so you're
gathering your tape for three months and
then you're making the actual thing for
to tip it like again it can be totally
different than that but that's some sort
of average I'm gonna pop in with one
more specific to kind of the podcast
that you guys do with related to the
sciences mm-hmm I guess I'm working with
the scientists first off is it is it
tough so you to get them to commit to
kind of taking a scientific finding or
advanced and technique and turning that
into a story that are long I guess like
in the sciences what is your approach to
kind of take Chris I mean your podcast
on CRISPR let's say or something like
that like what is your guys's approach
to taking something that's very
technically complicated and maybe a
scientist that is very knowledgeable and
turning that into something that's
digestible for the general public and
interesting right yeah and it's not just
in Sciences but in any interview I'll go
into like you just have to be dumb like
you have to like and you have to be
really certain of the things you don't
understand that they're saying so then
you can clearly articulate a question
that that answers that for you cuz yeah
a lot of times people are particularly
if it's a if it's a technical issue
they're talking about it with with a
fluency that nobody outside the field
has obviously so it's your job as the
interviewer or as the producer to to be
the idiot in the room and force them to
articulate it in a way that even the
dumbest person who's going to be
listening to the podcast would be able
to understand and also so you can truly
understand it because not only are we
talking to these people and using their
voice to explain what the ideas are but
we're intercutting our own voices so I
need to really clearly understand let's
say if I don't know like I keep coming
back to the Rhino hunter but I I need to
actually understand
the history of Namibia's conservation
policy be able to talk about it in a in
an educated let alone compelling way so
it's really about you in the moment very
very critically listening to the person
and then quickly coming up with the
question that resolves the issue that
you're feeling yourself have which is
which i think is just a great skill to
have in general
yeah just like being a very very active
listener and it's also about like
knowing when you're bored like that
that's one thing that we're always
trying to do because we're trying to
make stuff that's interesting and fun
right like we're we're not going to put
something out if it's not interesting
and so it part of the job is to also
just know what I'm interested in what
I'm curious about what I find a modicum
of Wonder in and then to chase that and
it's through the act of very critical
listening and like deep critical
awareness of of my own emotional states
as I'm taking in information that I that
I'm able to then hone in on not only
what I don't understand but what I do
truly find interesting so yeah it's a
it's a deep act of listening to you and
you have multiple going to tell me how
you idea yeah so again it totally varies
but I'd say about like five to six
months is probably a decent average and
so we've got what like six to eight
producers on staff at the moment and a
typical story is gonna have two
producers on it sometimes more sometimes
less and so we're sort of always trying
to have three or four things at
different phases of the production
process so that when we put one episode
out it's not like we're starting back at
square one and having to do in two weeks
all this work but rather we've got a
piece that's like 50% or 60% of the way
sort of produced and then it becomes
like polishing at the end those last two
weeks that very rarely happens and we're
constantly sprinting to try to find the
next thing or sprinting to try to finish
the thing that needs to come out next
but yeah in a perfect world it's like
this machine that has different
different stories moving at different
paces through different forms of the
production process
but yeah it's a [ __ ] show most of the
time kind of the integrity of what
whoever you're interviewing yes so there
are a couple I think when you down an
interview from 90 minutes to 20 minutes
there there's sort of two competing two
competing goals that you have one is to
preserve the character of the person as
much as possible and by that I don't
even necessarily mean what they said but
sort of how they said if they're giggles
they're the moments where they pause to
think if they're if like you as the
interviewer have a nice back-and-forth
of rapport with the person that's
important to capture and maintain and
then the other thing you're trying to do
is you're trying to cram in as much
information into those 20 minutes as
possible right there's many different
ideas as you can and it's a it's an
impossible balance in that you're always
gonna feel like stuff that you left on
the cutting room floor should have made
it into that little 20-minute cut but
the act of keeping them both both those
priorities in your head as you're moving
through the tape I think it's the best
way to approach it and how I do it is it
can 90-minute an interview I just listen
through it from
beginning to end the first time and I'm
literally cutting and pulling down the
moments I like very liberally so and
typically after my first passed through
a 90 minute interview I'll have about 40
minutes of tape that I pulled as my
favorite parts my favorite 40 minutes
and then from there what I do is I'll
sort of go through and listen through it
front to back again and start reordering
fills because what often happens in in
an interview is you're gonna have a lot
of the same ideas repeated throughout
different parts of the interview or even
in quick succession and so if I don't
know what what's an example here so I
was talking with these Content
moderators in the Philippines folks who
essentially it's their job to if you
flag something on facebook as
inappropriate it gets sent to Manila and
somebody sitting behind a computer then
has that image come across them and they
have to click yes is inappropriate or no
this is not inappropriate and so like
throughout the course my interview with
this guy I like came at him four times
with essentially variations of the same
question like wait so what does it look
like in your office like I'm trying to
actually imagine when you're sitting at
your computer what this looks like so
throughout the 90 minutes that's that
question is speckled through after I
pulled the 40 minutes of tape down I
started rearranging things so I have
like okay here are my four takes of the
guy answering this question maybe the
four it takes add up to a total of four
minutes long but he kind of says the
same thing each time I'm gonna be able
to cut that down to a minute or a minute
and a half sort of scrambling together
the best versions of him explaining that
and so after going through in a second
time you've reordered things then you
just start hacking stuff down and you
can usually get it down to 20 minutes
like it's sort of amazing in a 90 minute
conversation yeah you don't list off
times you don't actually need that much
more than 20 minutes to get the mate and
like the majority of the substance of
the conversation I hope that's not true
with what I'm saying right now I'm
hoping if they got down it would be hard
to get it down to 20 minutes but
partners
yes Oh like the reporting process or
like the ideation like how do we come up
with wit stories is that the question
okay yeah it's really hard because
they're like for something to work as a
radio lab story and this isn't true of
all podcast documentary programs but
like it there are a certain number of
boxes that need to be checked like you
got to have a character you have to have
a character that had something
interesting happened to them and then
that interesting unexpected thing that
happened to them
has to lead to some unexpected
interesting consequence so like that's
box one and that sort of near the the
building blocks or the foundation of the
narrative tension that I talked about
before it like you need to have
something happen that causes something
to make you give a damn about whatever
the hell this person has experienced on
top of that then like they have to be
able to tell their story in an
interesting ways so that you feel like
you can emotionally engage with them and
then on top of that like there has to be
as I said before like a question that
you're exploring and you need to have
like you you need or I need to be able
to articulate very clearly like I want
to do this story because I'm curious
about buppa buppa buckin a pro ch trying
to check all those boxes or finding
something that checks out those boxes
one is I come up with a question on my
own that I'm like oh I'm really curious
about like content moderation I was like
why is it such a hard problem to solve
the misinformation the rampant
misinformation on these social media
platforms why is that such a hard
problem to solve and that led me to go
find a bunch of people who are thinking
about this and doing this and and are
trying to solve it and could explain it
to me and through that I bumped into
people that have a story like the one I
mentioned before that something strange
happens to them and then they do
something strange in return the other
way is you just
like you just you can start with a
character like you find somebody who's
interesting like the the piece I did
about the city councilman like a year
before I even started reporting that
piece I reached out to the guy because I
had read an article about him and I
thought he was interesting and we like
would get coffee every couple months and
then from there as your report once I
started reporting out the story it's
figuring out what is the question that
I'm actually exploring through this but
Ness ins like I and its most basic is
just about input like you have to be
reading a lot you have to be talking to
a lot of people you have to be just sort
of a where you're like you're trying to
soak up as much of the world as you can
to then be able to figure out or feel
what in all of that mess is the most
interesting or the most confusing to you
but like if I'm if I have a day where
I'm just reporting and by reporting I
mean like looking for a story if I'm if
I'm hunting for stories I have just have
sort of a checklist that I go through
like I need to read five articles I need
to make two phone calls and I need to
schedule two more phone calls and if I
do that it becomes a numbers game and if
I do that enough days in a row I know
I'm eventually going to stumble into
something that gets me excited but it's
really hard it's really really hard
[Music]
sorry do you mind
sorry I don't mean interrupt but can you
talk a little bit louder I can't quite
hear you yeah sorry the question is like
how do you how you get people to agree
to talk and then how do you sort of make
them comfortable throughout the
interviewing process to talk about the
things that you want to talk about yeah
okay yeah it's weird it's a it totally
depends it depends on who they are it
depends on what their
why they're feeling ambivalent about
whether they want to talk to you or not
in the first place and then for me it's
it's about getting out in front of those
concerns that they have and to a degree
convincing them in a way that is
slightly manipulated but not maliciously
manipulative that they should talk to
you so for example there's this guy Judd
Hoffman who was Facebook's head of
global policy he was the guy who
essentially wrote the rulebook for what
is allowed to be on Facebook guy with a
ton of power guy with the story that I
think's fascinating and that I haven't
heard many people talk about like this
is the guy I want to get and we have
this wonderful phone call together like
I don't even bring up the possibility of
talking on the record and then at the
end of this hour and a half on the phone
I'm like so by the way would you be
comfortable talking on the record like
to be sort of have this conversation
again
but record it and he says like I don't
know if I'm gonna be able to do that
like I've really enjoyed this
conversation I'm just like I'm worried
that I'm gonna look like on Monday
morning quarterbacking here if I talk
about what Facebook's doing and more
than that like the company I work for
now and he worked for Pinterest he was
worried that they are going to like he
doesn't want what he says about Facebook
to in any way hurt Pinterest and so what
I did was I'm like I totally understand
that if nothing else can we just plan to
talk again because I'm sure I'll have
more questions off the record and he
said sure get shoot me an email with
some times to talk and so then when I do
is I spend like two and a half hours
crafting an email where in the first
paragraph I set up I propose some time
to talk but then like the real heart of
it is like this is I'm pitching him on
why he should go on the record and I'm
addressing point by point the issues
that he had when not wanting to do so
and obviously doing so in a in a
transparent way like and like winking at
the fact that I'm pitching you on this
and I know that you know that I'm trying
to get you to do something you don't
want to do but really just leveling with
them and I guess when I'm trying to get
people to talk on the record
in general I'm trying to use
transparency and authenticity as a tool
to get people to talk which is sort of
an odd thing because it's not
particularly authentic to use
authenticity in a calculated way but it
works and then as to like being on the
record with someone it's this weird
active sort of feeling it out at the
moment because the things that the
people don't that people don't want to
talk about are typically the things that
are the most interesting so it becomes
this game of you like walk the
conversation closer and closer to
whatever the question is that you really
want to ask and then you feel them sort
of bristle so you back up and you move
somewhere else but then again you push
back on it and then in the last 20% of
the interview is like hopefully you've
warmed them up to the idea of talking
about this hopefully they trust you a
bit at that point hopefully you are
trustworthy at that point and yeah you
just got to sort of hit him with the
question that really relates to me when
when you say that do you mean yeah I
guess I can you clarify the question a
little bit like like one that resonated
emotionally with me or yeah what exactly
what exactly do you mean yeah well I
guess what what I'm lucky in that my job
like every story I go after is because
I'm actually curious about some aspect
of it and occasionally I'll have to help
produce a story for someone else that
I'm not all that interested in but I
think every story I've certainly every
story I have I've reported what it was
was personally people in some way
because I just got to learn a lot and
satisfy a genuine curiosity recently I
did a story that I got to do with my dad
which was really fun so like that just
on a very personal level was very it was
very sad dying and it was just cool to
hear his voice on the radio but yeah I
think like hopefully and like whatever
field you all end up going into like
hopefully whatever you're doing does
satisfy you
both intellectually and emotionally
hopefully on like a regular basis I
think that's what everybody should be
striving for and I I I'm very lucky in
that my job does that for me so how do
you guys yeah interesting question I'm
trying to figure out how honest to be
here yeah maybe even that question was
planned by me to make you trust me more
I it's really I'll say two ends of the
spectrum here right one end of the
spectrum is we do have an audience and
it is reliably college educated and
reliably liberal or at least skews
Democratic we know that about our
audience we know what they want to hear
and we know sort of how far we can push
them so we're sort of always keeping
that in mind like we want to challenge
the audience with reason because we
challenge them too much
there can be backlash nobody's happy we
come off sounding tone-deaf so there's
that calculation being made of like we
got we got a we can't do too much here
but at the same time there's sort of the
Miles Davis approach which when Miles
Davis in his later years would play like
he'd go up on stage and he would instead
of having a microphone in front of him
looking out at the audience that he'd
play into he'd have a microphone like on
the ground at the back of the stage and
he'd just turned his audience never
turned his back to the audience and play
into his microphone sort of saying [ __ ]
you I'm gonna do my thing if you want to
listen to it you can't and so there's
like there's a there's like a swagger to
that and there's a confidence that like
what I find interesting will be
interesting to people that clearly if
you do that too much you're gonna come
across as an [ __ ] and you probably
are an [ __ ]
but uh like there there's a degree of
that that needs to that needs to be
inside of you as well when we're when
you're figuring out what it is you want
to spend six months of your life so like
sort of love the audience but forget
about the audience I think is one way we
think about it I don't know if that's
applicable to what you all do to push
back on me if you think I'm totally
wrong yeah yeah yeah I think I'll sort
of go back to one of my earlier answers
and just say like I think it's being
able there's a confidence in being able
to be stupid in front of very smart
people and to be able to be stupid in a
very smart way
to know when they're not quite
articulating their themselves well
enough for the average person to be able
to hear and for you to be able to jump
in and say like whoa I'm sorry I didn't
quite understand that are you saying it
this way or is this what you mean or is
this what you mean because I'm not quite
sure and that again is a is a can only
happen when once you've really developed
an ability to listen critically so being
at being a critical listener yeah are
you actually kind of know they kind of
say but trying and when you do that have
you I guess not come across as fake yeah
good question
I'm totally playing them like I don't
know if I Drive I don't know if I would
use the term playing devil's advocate
but but certainly I'm making arguments
that I don't agree with at times to push
someone to more clearly articulate their
argument or I'm even oftimes I'm playing
dumb when I understand something or it's
as straight it's as small a thing is
like well I'm saying something like I
hear that they bumped the microphone I
might say like sorry I didn't quite
understand that could you say that again
just so we have like a clear piece of
tape of them saying it and as far as
like doing it in a way that doesn't feel
over the top or performed like I think
at least for me like I I approach
interviewing as a sort of active
performance like I am a different person
when I'm interviewing than I am in the
rest of my life I don't think I'm a it's
a version of myself like it's a slightly
more heightened version more excited
version or more easily excited person
and and as far as like do I know what
they're going to say when I enter
the room I all off times have a good
idea and if I do then that gives me some
lead time and prior to the interview to
to sort of prepare a list of counter
arguments for what I expect them to say
but at the same time like you know any
at least the ethos here is you don't
want to prep too much because you want
to be able to have an actual genuine
back-and-forth with the person and be
present and allow yourself to think
through something with them in any given
moment so yeah it's it's a I think it's
something you can only learn by doing
and sort of dialing dialing yourself in
and how how you want to be in that space
which is a totally unsatisfactory answer
and I'm sorry about that
even just popped in with a question that
they wanted to ask elaborate on training
specifically yeah the question is like
how did I how did I learn how to do some
of this stuff like particularly critical
listening and okay so I didn't I didn't
study journalism I have no background in
it I when I was 20 22 I was living down
in South America
working at a couple restaurants just
trying to master the Spanish language
and while I was doing that I realized
like what the hell am I going to do with
my life and felt like you know I like to
write I listen to a lot of public radio
I had played in bands so I understood
audio to a degree and so I decided like
well let's move somewhere new in Latin
America and just try being a reporter
for the freelance reporter and I knew
that there were interesting things going
on in Venezuela and that nobody are very
few english-speaking reporters were
there so I moved to Venezuela and just
started pitching places like going out
trying to find stories pitching those
story ideas to different editors until I
eventually got picked up by the BBC's
the world and from there I moved to
Ireland I did that again
and working for an English speaking
German radio show and then from there I
got I got an internship here at the show
so like what can be learned from that I
think the most important thing is just
to stuff like if you if and not not that
you all want to be journalists but just
like you just have to start making stuff
you just have to start doing stuff and
don't wait for somebody to don't wait to
get permission don't necessarily wait to
have all of the skills before you start
just you're gonna learn stuff as you're
probably gonna learn things more quickly
potentially by just doing them so
there's that aspect of it I will say I
showed up to the show here and was
totally like out of my depth like and I
mean that in not just a journalistic way
but like I grew up in Wisconsin I didn't
get a great education I went to a state
school in Oregon for college and
suddenly I'm with all these Ivy League
[ __ ] who think super fast and and
are just way better read than me and so
it was like this three years of just
educating myself so that I could even
have conversations with people and so
again like there was a lot of self
education there and I was surrounded by
really as you all clearly are really
smart thoughtful people who were patient
with me and helped me along the way so
yeah I think they're all very learnable
skills I don't think there's any sort of
yeah I don't know if there's an innate
miss to it at all the only other one one
thing I will say is I think the way I
learned and I didn't even know I was
learning to be an interviewer but the
way I learned how the interview was like
I hitchhiked a bunch in college and when
you're hitchhiking like you're just
sitting in the passenger seat and you
have nothing to do but talk to the
person and they're giving you arrived so
to a degree I felt sort of indebted to
them and the way I would pay them back
was by asking them questions about like
who they are what they were up to and
I think I honed that skill in those long
car rides I don't know if I suggest that
people do that or not but it works okay
yeah really really do you have any
stories like Chris was saying that
really failures or flops that like you
know he was like across earth there was
background or anything like that oh yeah
yeah I know the biggest one was this
episode that we put out called truth
trolls which got pulled down which we
ended up retracting and essentially it
was the story of 4chan trolling Shia
LaBeouf and this art project he was
doing and how through incredible wit
perseverance and critical thought they
were able to locate where this where
this flag was located knowing nothing
more than a live stream video of the
flag and it's an incredible story like
it in and of itself the fact that these
guys managed to pull this off I think is
it's incredible
now clearly where we failed was that we
didn't articulate clearly enough that
there are a lot of bad actors on fortune
and that it's even possible that some of
the guys who ended up doing this were
those bad actors and so for that reason
and also in part because the episode
came out like the day before
Charlottesville so suddenly the national
conversation and just the national mood
changed in this very dark way and
rightfully so it just it even fell to us
that what we had done was tone-deaf what
I what I think was important about that
piece and what I can you Inc to strive
to do despite in this this sort of comes
with the pushing the audience is like I
think that
what a court bad people can still have
rich complicated interesting lives and
that just because like III think you can
you can present someone's story without
glorifying the horrible views that they
might have and that's a really hard
thing because like there's always gonna
be a good portion of the audience who
thinks like you just shouldn't even give
this person a platform which like I'm
happy to have that argument and I think
you whoever someone who is articulate
that like they're they have plenty of
good arguments they could use but I
guess my like a principal I have is like
it's better to see other people as human
than not and if I can find a an iota of
entity and someone it's not only worth
presenting but I think it's also just
deeply interesting but yeah that was one
that we we missed the mark on in several
ways and we acknowledged yeah we [ __ ]
up so first up thank you very much for
taking the time so yeah this was super
interesting and I'll send you a
follow-up email I guess I got to get
some paper permission to post the
recording Cornell policy stuff but yeah
no this is this is awesome thank you
very much well and I I don't think all
Ivy Leaguers are [ __ ] alright